[Music]
Peach you're so
cool and with my star we're going to
rule
Peach
understand I'm on to love you till the
very end
peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches
peaches peaches peaches peaches
peaches yeah
oh
PES
[Music]
PES what a report from our intelligence
a Mustachio old human has arrived in the
Mushroom
Kingdom the princess has been training
him they are up to something
sire
sit jam with
[Music]
me this uh human where did he come from
we ar sure does the princess like him s
look in the mirror you have nothing to
worry about I know that I'm not
threatened a
find out who he is and what they're
planning I'm on it s may I lift the
cover not yet pain is the best
[Music]
teacher I stay out too
late got nothing in my
brain that's what people say m that's
what people say m I go up to many dayses
but I
make at least
people people are you getting this
IU
stop I got this music in my mind saying
it's going to be all
[Music]
right
I never miss a
be running on
[Music]
theet
see
MH going to
play and the going to hey hey hey hey he
baby I'm just going to shake shake shake
shake shake shake it off shake it off
oh aren't they great are you kidding me
it's like watching Jello dancing around
like you could do any better
pipsqueak all all right all right hey
you want to see something great I'll
show you
great
bre
going I'm just going to
shake shake it out I shake it
Shake It Off Shake It Off ah Shake It
Off shake it off shake it shake
it shake it shake
[Music]
it gter and
Rosita
Morman
[Music]
all right piggy
[Applause]
power that was
[Music]
great
iners there they are hey you don't
[Music]
move come here come
here
[Music]
but no no no no no no
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
Sal
[Applause]
don't
move hands in the
[Music]
air you can never know what it's like
your blood like a winter freeze just
like ice and there's a cold lonely light
that shines from you wind up like a
wreck you hide behind
[Music]
that what is that turn it down will
you boy didn't you hear me I said turn
it Johny don't you know I'm still
standing better than I ever did look
like a true sural jie I'm feeling like a
little kid it's
Julie after all this time I'm picking up
the pieces of my life without you own my
mind I'm still
standing yeah yeah
yeah I'm still
standing
yeah
watch
again theats to down and was cir so you
feel by now don't you know I'm still
standing better than I ever did looking
like a true
survivor I'm feeling like a little
kid now still standing after all this
time I'm picking up the pieces of my
life with without you on my mind I'm
still
standing yeah yeah
yeah I'm still
yeah what about that huh give it up for
Johnny
F
what's with the face you were great they
loved
you yeah
[Music]
thanks
okay
hello please you're not allowed in
without an adult scram
[Music]
holigans how many tickets please yeah
to try
please oh no please
[Music]
Uno enjoy yourself love thank
you
okay come hey what are you doing
here this is a restricted area hands in
the
[Music]
air stop
there get
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
Judi you are all trespassing a priv
property and you will leave right now no
no no no no no all of
you got burned got broken down by desire
I tried I tried but the smoke in my eyes
let me
blurry blurry in mind I all the pieces
up off
[Music]
the I am calling the
police stick into the plan says I can't
do anything H I can do anything at all
this is my Cas goodby you can stand
Watch Me Fly cuz nothing's keeping me
down on stay right
now G seriously she's not even that
good yeah yeah
totally here and Never Letting Go I can
finally see just a dream when you set it
up free up free up free you set it
[Music]
up this is my
big I'm here Never Letting Go I can
finally see it's not just a dream when
you set it all free all free all free
you set it all
[Music]
free I you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
okay yeah bad
right
[Applause]
[Music]
how bad can I be I'm just doing what
comes naturally how bad can I be I'm
just following my destiny how bad can I
be I'm just doing what comes naturally
how bad can I be how bad can I possibly
be well there's a principle in nature
principle in nature that almost every
creature knows called survival of the
Fest and check it this is how it goes
the animal that wins got to scratch and
fight and Claw and bite and punch and
the animal that doesn't well the animal
that doesn't winds up someone else
say
[Music]
lunch I'm just saying how can I be I'm
just doing what comes naturally how bad
can I be I'm just following my destiny
how bad can I be I'm just doing what
comes naturally how badad can I be how
bad can I possibly be there's a
principal in business principal in
business that everybody knows it sound
it says the people with the money people
with the money make this every loving
world go round so I'm bigger in my
company I'm bigger in my factory I'm
bigger in my corporate sign everybody
out there you take care of yours oh take
care of my M shake that bottom line let
me hear you say SM you little
smity all you want is never ever ever
ever going to
stop come on how bad can it possibly be
how bad can I be I'm just building the
economy how bad can I be just look at me
petting this puppy how bad can can I be
a portion of proceeds goes to charity
how bad can I be how bad could I
possibly be let's
see all the customers are
buying and the money
multiplying and the pr people are
lying and the lawyers are
denying who cares if a few trees are
dying this is all gratifying how
bad how bad can this possibly
be I have
climb the highest
mountains I have
run through the
fields only to be with
you only to be with
you but I
still haven't
found what I'm looking
[Music]
for but I
still haven't
found what I'm looking
for
but I
still haven't
found what I'm looking
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
I believe in the Kingdom Come Bear all
the colors with bed into one
bed into
one we yes I'm still
running you brought the bar and
lose the chain you carry the
cross of my
shame I
mer you know I believe
it but I
still haven't
found what I'm looking
[Music]
for but I
still have a
what I'm looking
[Music]
for I
Still Haven't
Found What I'm Looking
For I
still haven't
found what I'm looking
[Music]
for
mission accomplished we're heading
[Applause]
[Music]
home oh we're the Mario brothers and
plumbing a game we're not like the
others who all the fame when your si is
in trouble you could call us on the
double we're faster than the others
you'll be hooked on the
brothers and the Luigi are you tired of
paying too much for pluming Mama M
that's why the Super Mario Brothers are
here to save Brooklyn and the queens and
your wallet thank you Super Mario Bros
it seems like the only thing you haven't
drained is my bank account forget that
the expensive app pluming companies
where you're just a face with the Super
Mario Brothers
family the brothers Brothers
brother wow you were great mission
report my search takes me to the second
planet the planet of Joy all right here
we go pora time to show the world what
you're really
made don't want to live is an UNT story
rather go out in a place of Glory I
can't hear you I don't fear you I live
now cuz the bad
di bullets with your broken
pass can't he you I don't fear you
now hey who the heck are you where's my
security we security now mate
what I want to taste love and pain want
to feel pride and shame I don't want to
take my time don't want to waste one
line I want to live better days never
look back and say it could have been me
me it could have been
me
yeah don't want to wake up on a Monday
morning get get off of there don't you
make me come out
there
here you
now R in your regret what a waste of
blood and sweat
oh
[Applause]
taste you traitor that's it I'm coming
out
there Miss Crowley put some cushions and
snacks down there so you should be
comfortable till the show's over you
little in
pain to
feel don't want
to don't want to
my never
will it could have been
me oh it could have been
me it could have
[Music]
B bye snowball bye Mr
bear panda panda panda panda panda panda
listen
hey I got BRS in Atlanta Twisted Rock
dring F credit cards in the scammers H
licks in the B black6 pH wait and see
look like a
panda listen scammers black wa Panda SW
Danny Candy Man I'm The Macho like
Randy
back
ready Gina it's Mina wait what is never
mind listen find that feeling it is now
or
[Music]
never okay okayy I'm ready
now before I put on my make I say a
little PR for
[Music]
you comb in my
head
[Music]
Wonder for you for you forever ever in
my heart I will love you forever ever
you oh how I
love what Mr Crystal where are you I'm
trapped somewhere under the stage I'll
find you sir Mr Crystal I'm
coming
[Music]
iing
at work I just take
time and myof break time I say a little
prep for
you again I will love
you love
you
[Music]
together be
only be heart
break for
[Music]
me yes I am going to win a ton of awards
for this
hi um hi I'm Mina oh um
Alonso you you were incredible so were
you um what oh uh never mind um want to
meet up after the show maybe uh okay
okay great
[Music]
[Applause]
bye you don't know me but my name's
I'm just the old delivery
guy but it seems like trees might be
worth a
try so I say Let It
[Music]
Grow my name is Dan and my's Rose our
Wesley kind of glows and that's not good
so we suppose we should let it grow let
it grow let it grow you can't and read
what you don't s fantasy inside the
earth just one way to know it's worth
let's the
world it my name's Marie and I am three
I would really like to see a tree
La I say Let It Grow I'm gry Norma I'm
old and I've got gray hair but I
remember when trees were everywhere and
no one to pay for air so I say let it
grow let it it like
Ito it is just one tiny SK but it's all
we really need it's time to change the
life my name's ohir I'm one of you I
live here in Neville
too the things you say just might be
true it could be time to start a new and
maybe change my point of
view nah I say let it die let it die let
it die let it shrivel up and come on
who's with me huh
nobody you greeted dirt
B let love inside
show
[Music]
world it's just time see but it's all we
really time to all
[Music]
your and let this be
our
thank you
[Music]
Ted
[Applause]
here comes Peter Cotton Tail down the
bunny trail hippity hoity Easter on
[Music]
it what is that Dreadful sound make your
Easter and
gay he's got
oh no they found me run it's the pink
Beres oh uh never mind everyone falce
alarm please continue with your awful
singing how did that rabbit just
talk um Fred's been studying
ventriloquism
yeah I um I might do it professionally
woohoo you're being ridiculous stop it
sit down you should be nicer to your son
well it's just it's just a
thought who wants to hear a song we'd
love to sing a song for you no we
wouldn't FR stop making fool of yourself
sit down absolutely I want
candy
I want
candy take it
kids I know a girl who's tough
[Music]
sweet she's so fine she can't be
me she's got everything desire he's
really good I can see his lips sets the
Summer sun on
fire
[Music]
candy I want
candy problem now I want
candy now the crumpy done I want
candy all I want is your
candy all I want is
your one to eat on sweet
[Music]
they're a hit they love
us